dar es tout seul là bas à la louve
walter hagen mon uniforme et et aux
salles la grand-mère de se soustraire
ses dosettes se défend d'ailleurs bon
recevoir les gens auraient supérieur des
gens mais il faut ranger tout était 40e
n 4 sont disponibles dans l'armure j'ai
le trac en larmes sur les gens mais ce
super pistonné avec une seule balle dans
charger j'ai dit qu'une seule plus tard
deux balles dans le chargeur s'entendait
bordel bien commencé c'est la mer
retirée qui va fermer des nouvelles
commandes
je voulais tirer dessus pour mettre
chargement
bon tu sors là c'est alors au tour en 70
kg biais même cave de santé uniquement
d'entre elles vous retirer toutes ses
balles à part fait mal sur le champ de
bataille n'aurait droit de tirer
doucement sur lui à rex est finie balle
si vous doublez c'est enfantin voit le
corps à corps et le côté offensif et
leur famille leur survie c'est compris
des questions et à celles visées le quad
est donc bien jouer tu ma voiture mais
ne voulait pas voir ado c'est à bâle
pour en avoir toujours une dent charger
de tout le monde s'est excusé on se
retrouve aujourd'hui sur black ops
l'uimm va charger et vous louerez grêlé
compris les délégués grâce à cette
superbe intro ensuite alors j'ai loupé
grâce à cette superbe treuil à rennes en
fait je vous expliquais un peu
l'histoire de cette intro c'est tout
simplement que j'étais en cours
d'histoire voyez un nom en cours de
français pardon mais je me suis dit mais
mais mais mais si un jour l'armée
arrivait à faire une balle chargé mais
hier elle ça serait vraiment débile et
regardez on va en avoir là non ah ouais
non mais non mais je suis en tactique
c'était d'un coût modique
je suis dégouté je suis déjà à ma
dernière millions il faut qu'on se
concentre un jour fake non non non non
non non non yes ok on l'a eu il y en a
un là non ouais ok non à un mât boyle va
pas ils m'appellent team a loupé oh là
là là là là là mais quel mais c'est
vraiment mais c'est tendu ce mode je
vous jure l'asile bien bien bien je sais
que tu m'as lopez est bien bien voilà
très bien comme ça attention le deuxième
il est là bas on va on va la voir hier
l'évanescente par le haut ou par le bas
abricot porte très bien donc je me suis
dit allez on doit y avoir forcément un
truc à elle complètement coup imaginez
dans la vraie vie une balle chargé
l'armée tout ça mais ce doit être à se
se chier dessus de rire car pendant la
guerre c'est pas marrant sérieusement
les soldes au nom au moment où je tire
c'est dégueulasse et dégueulasse ça doit
être marrant un poème de se dire dédié à
la guerre les légendes et tirait une
balle forains disons par exemple pour
rire sauf les gens de cherrie que une
balle a pu depuis travaillé comme des
malades à la cahc écoutait tout quoi
france je me suis dit bon ça serait
totalement débile mais voilà je me sens
un peu moqué de colloques mais bon enfin
moquer entre guillemets entre guillemets
puisque call of ne se vend pas du tout
sur le réalisme des jeux qu'au contraire
ils disent bugs et arcade ou quoi et
c'est ça qui fait qu'on aime colloque
c'est d'un côté ce côté bien arcade on
va enchaîner sur une deuxième partie les
gens c'est vrai que ça allait très vite
[ __ ] avant tout cas j'ai fini 1er
voilà on sait déjà c'est déjà ça et lui
m'insupporte il s'appelle voix de merde
merci je bénis et celui qui a inventé ce
petit bouton mais juste la voix papa ben
désolé je me permets tout simplement net
la vidéo en pause puisque la recherche
va quelque peu buggé et pendant trois
minutes vous allez voir un [ __ ] de
manuela qu'on est intéressant donc j'ai
décidé après coup de faire un petit
gameplay rapidement et vous le maître
pendant ces trois minutes voilà c'est
pour ça que ce ne sera pas une bâche
chargé mais de la domination a tout de
suite ou simple sympa enfin bon alors
écouter les gens j'ai plutôt beaucoup de
choses à vous dire notamment quelque
chose qui m'a incroyablement choqué
récemment alors je suis allé à une
petite soirée avec notamment avec jay z
et sa bande va être quoi 7,7 maximum et
il se trouve que c'est pas si c'est
normal mais je trouve que le chien bon
vous allez dire exclusive du pic à la
loyola bologne a dit ce que vous vouliez
penser ce que vous voulez mais
sérieusement je vous demande à vous et
heureusement est ce que c'est normal que
le chien de mon pote et manger c
dire c'est ce sont kaka quoi en gros il
il a mangé du lièvre on sait pas ce
qu'il y avait des traces sur le pinceau
journal et doit faire ça il est tout
petit il doit avoir trois - et tous les
trop marrant et on se demandait si
c'était normal fabrèges de zapper ce
sujet quand même dans des villes telles
que j'ai pêché à un veau le pied c'est
vrai que c'était un sujet vraiment
débile et je m'en excuse ma foi mon plus
beau du monde
et que dire que dire sur black up c'est
sûr je pense que le les modes de black
up genre une balle chargé et john games
et tout ça ils vont arriver forcément en
ligne sur un double des trois jeux j'y
pense je suis presque sûr je bois une
gorgée de coca de seconde parce que
regarder déjà le moins d'infections qui
est disponible en privé ils ont rajouté
sur sur le w3 online et je pense que
sachant qu'en privé il ya aussi de bâle
chargé gun game et ça je crois même mois
de mars que bon je pense qu'ils mettront
tout ça sur le mode hors ligne mais vous
faire ça au fur et à mesure même et web
sinon je pense que mw3 je pense de cette
communauté afin qu'un pas que cette
communauté mais que tout le monde on
fait trop de vidéos sur un doublé 3 les
youtuber toutes races tout le monde
tout le monde fait trop d'erreurs sur
level 3 et je pense que ce sera une des
cause pour laquelle il va lui tu nous
l'as c'est à dire que par exemple je
sais pas vous mais moi maintenant un
montage je le regarde enfin montage bon
si c'est un mets amis par exemple rambo
warcraft iii ou
soit je regarde mon temps on voyait
enfin je regarde tout mon talent mais
franchement sinon je trouve que bon bout
d'un moment on voit la lunule deux
minutes ok ça va je pense que c'est
assez répétitif et que maintenant pour
faire des trucs de ma la fin maintenant
pour impressionner les gens et faire des
montages qui ont qui feront un véritable
buzz colline zumba faudra faire des
noces copé cross 5,5 et schott nana fin
voilà vous voyez le truc un but que je
veux dire mais je pense qu'en tout cas
le w3 on s'en est pris plein la gueule
en très peu de temps
ah je pense que ça sera une des cause
pour laquelle google travaille à ses
fins après c'est ce que je pense et ce
que je crois même si je vous respecte
très bien si vous vous en êtes
absolument pas et que vous adorez
toujours ce pépin de jeu sur lequel
ouvrages tous comme des porcs fin
notamment ben c'est vrai qu'ils vont
aller les biens rage on peut pas dire le
contraire mais franchement les gens
essayer de revenir sur un colloque par
exemple code 4 cote 56 scott cette coque
trois tonnes de coke enfin tous les call
of duty surpris oui vous allez voir ce
que vous voulez hein mais vraiment vous
allez voir que notamment celui là le
blaco ce livre rien j'étais le premier à
sa sortie un fairway cette année à mal
maintenant la belge avoue en même temps
ça j'avais joué tu peux moi elle w2
essayé blackops était sorti et j'étais
là où elle est nulle et des nuages
étaient vraiment un chieur total
mais en fait il a son charme sincèrement
de la cote à son petit charme bon ça
n'empêche pas exact la ville qui les
médias veuillez en aura vu diverses
enfin tous les bugs possibles et
inimaginables surtout sur pas notamment
sur un plateau mais du club ou quoi et
je pense mais ce drame le jeu qui allait
peuvent les plus marrants ces fifa les
genres arche franchement mais les bottes
de pluie femme et ils sont mes a à
manger son caca comme le chien ne monte
pas gamins sans réciter ses débuts non
je vais arrêter
mr je me sens mal je roi du coq à l'âme
être même un petit peu de max voilà très
bien attention ouais voilà donc
donc l'idée lario avait que je sais plus
voila voila j'ai fait le con je me
souviens le enfin oui je disais que
c'est vraiment les bugs voilà de fifa
sont tout simplement épique est vraiment
mais c'est vraiment mais c'est vraiment
épique et pic et pic et l'adoption au
genre au fake aille à moi je crie le
fake je crie le fais attention non non
non non
oui non non non non non hélène baslé
hausse hier bah oui ça lui non ouais
mais auquel vous avez vu comme je disais
non
il avait deux balles fac et la vague
john mahon sans rien c'était incroyable
et de balais je disais ouais vraiment
par exemple les gens qui tombent et qui
tourne sur leur sur leur tête et tout en
tombant en fin dé des trucs mais
complètement débile mais ce qui m'a
aussi que c'est des bugs réalise ou
laisser qu'on s'imagine une personne
dans la vraie vie faire ça et là on
rigole un groupe non oui
yes parfait alors attention il va
falloir qu'on a sur le coup là messieurs
dames up de m'attendre
il y en a un qui monte attention
ouais ok ou sans nom je fais des supers
bruit [ __ ] merde dernière vit dernière
vit dernière vie il est le vrai goût
pour les besoins de la vidéo
wahou mon pauvre tu n'as rien vu venir
et tu te fais éclater atomisé bon alors
maintenant je la veux espion on n'a pas
joli casque âge j'étais concentré et
bien voilà ces deux parties où je finis
premier mais franchement ce qui est
dommage avec ce mode bâle chargé c'est
le truc entre les parties il est lu long
mais il est long il est d'une longueur
au regard d un arc en ciel ont r j'ai
jamais vu mais comment c'est possible
qu'il y ait un arc-en-ciel s'il ne pleut
pas penser que à moins que l'air soit
très humide
ben ouais ça va être faisait un bon je
ne sais pas en tout cas j'espère que
cette petite vidéo détente on va dire en
vain j'ai ouais j'espère que cette
petite vidéo détente sur black ops ont
une balle chargé vous aura plu on se
retrouve bientôt je pense pour une vidéo
je vais peut-être faire du sel trouve
c'est quoi dans la description il y aura
un sondage pour voir si vous voulez que
je refasse des vidéos sur le centro
notamment à oops roues par exemple n'ont
pas toutes les missions quoi puisque je
vais vraiment très long mais meiway par
exemple une mission sur le 3g la fois en
vidéo
ça pourrait être sympa je pense ça
pourrait être marrant et avec c'est un
jeu très fun et que j'adore le fun donc
voilà écoute et n'oubliez pas de passer
voter le petit sondage dans la
description n'y a pas besoin
d'inscription ou quoi que ce soit c'est
vous avez juste à cliquer et puis voilà
on se retrouve bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo chat au monde